the facebook oversight board says that
the company was right to ban president
trump
war breaks out inside the house gop over
liz cheney and the democratic party
continues to promote economic
immigration and covid idiocy i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a quick reminder we are now
spending more money than has ever been
seen
by god or man and this is going to lead
to inflation and even janet yellen the
treasury secretary she basically
acknowledged inflation is probably on
its way
so if you're looking at the value of
your bank account and thinking well
through no fault of my own this is going
to be worth less tomorrow than it is
today
perhaps you might think about
diversifying into precious metals which
is the greatest hedge
against inflation and uncertainty in the
markets if all your investments are tied
to dollars you're sitting on a ticking
time bomb do what i do
invest a portion of your savings into
gold and silver birch gold group those
are the people i trust you can trust
them to convert an ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
that's right through a little-known tax
loophole you can convert your retirement
savings that are tied to the stock
market
into an ira backed by precious metals
that would be your hedge against
inflation i'm not saying take every
dollar you have take it out of the stock
market real estate and toss it into gold
and silver i'm saying you need a little
bit of your money in precious metals
text ben to 4747.47 for your free
information kit on precious metals ira
or to speak with a birch gold
representative today with ten thousand
customers
an a plus rating with the better
business bureau and countless five star
reviews birch gold can help you too
text ben to 47 47 47 invest in cold
before it is too late alrighty so the
big news today
is that facebook has decided hey yeah it
turns out that when we ban trump
on january 6 we're right we're right all
along so here's what you have to know
facebook last year set up what they
called their facebook oversight board
and the facebook oversight board was
supposed to be the sort of outside
independent group that facebook did not
control
that was supposed to make decisions it
was sort of like an appellate court that
if somebody appealed the decision made
by facebook it's either its algorithms
or its employees that you could appeal
to this facebook court and the facebook
court would make a decision as to
whether that person should have been
suspended
or banned or something and the
constituency of the court was already
weird right the oversight board was
already strange
because it included a bunch of various
sort of advocates from a variety of
countries
which first of all doesn't make any
sense because the united states has the
most open free
speech standards on planet earth right
we are more free
pro-free speech in the united states
than they are in canada or than they are
in the uk certainly in the rest of
europe
and yet the oversight board was made up
of a bunch of people who don't even live
in america
there is like one third of the board was
made up of americans and the other two
thirds
were people who were not american then
it was made up of a bunch of people who
were politically active
and it was not made politically diverse
there were like a couple of people
who were on the facebook oversight board
who could theoretically be considered
conservative and then the rest
were not right so they created basically
an oversight board that was supposed to
act as
what sounded more like a pr agency for
facebook
it would relieve facebook of the
responsibility they could always just
say listen it wasn't us it was this
independent body over here
who decided that we were right or wrong
to do what we did
and the truth is that facebook has
always sort of wanted to do this this is
why facebook has said we'd rather that
you guys regulate us in government than
that we regulate ourselves because they
don't want the responsibility for this
they just want to make money
right there's never been any clear
standard applied either by facebook
within
or by any party without so they've been
searching for some way to sh
to shift responsibility from the
decision makers in facebook
to some other body so they can just go
about their business and do social media
in
and not have to worry about what
standards of free speech ought to apply
or ought not to apply
now that is a shift in facebook's
perspective from the past
if you go back to 2010 if you go back to
mark zuckerberg used to make statements
routinely about how the goal here was to
allow more speech not less
in 2019 he gave an excellent speech at
georgetown university in which he said
the messiness of free speech
is part and parcel of the right of free
speech and we can either have a less
messy first amendment
and more tyranny or we can have a more
messy first amendment and less tyranny
which is exactly correct his standards
on free speech
sounded very much like the normal
constitutional standards of free speech
but then there was pressure the pressure
that was applied to facebook
in the aftermath of the 2016 election
particularly by democrats was quite
severe
before 2016 facebook was seen as the
wave of the future by the democrats they
love facebook right barack obama knew
how to use it
the obama campaign had done great with
it in 2012 they were all geniuses over
there
and then there's the cambridge analytica
non-scandal which really was not a
scandal
and the media blew it up they were
looking for an excuse as to why hillary
clinton had lost the 2016 election
and the excuse they came up with was not
that she was the world's crappiest
candidate
awful ran a terrible campaign and nobody
liked her their excuse was
simultaneously it was the russians and
also his social media if social media
had just cracked down on the
misinformation from republicans and the
disinformation from the russians
hillary clinton certainly would have won
right this was the lie that was told as
opposed to you know hillary clinton was
just a crappy candidate
which happens to be the truth and the
social media companies because they are
run by people
who generally vote democrat they were
resonant to this they were like oh well
maybe that's true maybe we need to start
cracking down on speech maybe we need
instead of just worrying about upholding
people's power to speak
we need to cultivate conversations we
need conversations
that foster better public dialogue right
which means that they were now going to
insert themselves into the business of
deciding what content could go up and
what content
could go down now this was not really
their job
right the basis for social media has
always been in the united states section
230 of the communications decency act of
1996.
that section 230 was specifically
designed in order
to allow companies like facebook or like
youtube
to create platforms for people to post
their own content
without the company gaining the
liability of the content
if you post some sort of defamatory
material on facebook facebook
is not responsible for the defamatory
material you are responsible
for the defamatory material that was the
purpose of the communications decency
act
and it was meant to foster more
conversation
then because there were some court
decisions that suggested
that if a website started taking down
comments that were obscene and lewd
they would then be held liable for the
other comments that they left up
that's when section 230 was added
section 230 said
that there could be some cultivation of
the comments
sections right that these big companies
didn't become publishers
just by virtue of taking down
pornographic material in the comment
sections
or spamming material in the comment
sections so there's this catch-all
provision in section 230 of the
communications decency act
that says that the there's you don't
really need an excuse to take down
material so
an act that was designed to foster free
conversation was then used post 2016 by
the social media tech bros in order to
stop conversation because now the idea
was well you know it says in section 230
we can take down whatever we want
we're not liable for the stuff that we
leave up so
they they actually flipped the purpose
of section 230 on its head
and you started to see the social media
companies get much more heavily invested
in censorship in banning people you'd
see these coordinated censorship
campaigns
or people who i personally think are
terrible but
certainly had not violated rules started
to see their accounts just disappear
they started to see people who i think
are just garbage you know the the alex
jones the milo yiannopoulos of the world
they would lose their account but i
would say like why are they losing their
account
even though they personally target me i
can take it i mean that's free speech
that's the way things are supposed to
work
but these social media companies rarely
gave any sort of consistent excuse
because they would leave up louis
farrakhan and ayatollah khamenei and
they would take down milo yiannopoulos
or alex jones and then finally they got
to president trump on january 6th we'll
get to this in just
one second first let us talk
about the simple fact that if you want a
great t-shirt there's one
place to go i'm talking about cuts it's
not just t-shirts it's polos
it is it is all sorts of great stuff
their shirts are the best
cuts clothing shirts they are the best
they've taken the classic men's fashion
staple the plain tee they've refined it
they've combined premium quality with a
minimalist aesthetic they've got shirts
polos hoodies crew sweatshirts they're
all made for the man
who works hard plays hard never settles
for less all in the sport
of business i literally throw out all my
other t-shirts cuts is just that
comfortable it fits
just that well it's the perfect t-shirt
accomplished
next cuts set out to create fabric
uniquely engineered for each clothing
style
consider the new cuts hoodie they
developed hyperloop french terry fabric
a textile that is temperature
controlled and ageless you never need to
take it off
and you won't want to or try their
wrinkle-free pika polo
a design that keeps you fitted for the
office the golf course at home the gym
or the next date
is not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing it's office leisure apparel for
the sport of business get 15
off your first order by heading on over
to cutsclothing.com
shapiro that is cutsclothing.com for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing okay so
as these social media companies
particularly twitter started to crack
down more and more heavily
on content there was additional pressure
brought on places like facebook to crack
down additionally on content and
democrats started openly threatening
places like facebook senator dianne
feinstein would call in
zuckerberg in front of her and say
things like if you don't crack down on
content well then we will which of
course
they can't because of this thing called
the first amendment but the threat
has been there from democrats for a very
long time either the social media
companies
would become tools of the democratic
party or they would meet the heavy hand
of government
this was the threat because here's the
thing about social media what social
media actually did in effect
is it allowed alternative media like the
daily wire to flourish
i'm very grateful for the presence of
facebook because otherwise i couldn't
get my material to you
okay the reality is that these giant
social media companies blew
up the monopoly that had been held
heretofore by the giants establishment
media companies these establishment
media companies
and the democrats then got angry they
didn't like the fact that there were so
many alternative sources of media
that were capable of reaching the
american people directly so then they
started trying to blackmail these
companies saying okay you need to shut
down all these alternative sources of
media
and then we will let you thrive and this
is why you see people like nancy pelosi
again the tech bros are all democrats
this is why i see people like nancy
pelosi saying
you know i don't really like facebook
i'm not a big fan of facebook
they have had a business model uh that
is a business model big
built on making money on
misrepresentations
uh so for a long time they made money on
russian money coming in and distorting
our
our elections and saying well we didn't
know it was russian well they're rupals
okay uh so i'm not again a big fan of
those so
they're if they're making a business
decision uh then uh
that's one thing if they're making a
values decision
uh then that would be another okay so
that is nancy pelosi openly urging
facebook to ban
trump right he was talking about this
yesterday so democrats decided that
social media
are only their friends when they do what
they want so facebook decided you know
what i don't want to be in the middle of
this right zuckerberg said i don't want
to be in the middle of this
facebook's board basically said we'll
create this outside oversight board
and you want to blame somebody to blame
them in the same way that the
legislature of the united states has
basically set up
all these executive branch agencies to
do the regulations so they don't get
blamed
same thing facebook's doing they're like
we're going to kick the can down the
road we don't want to own this thing so
we've set up this oversight board filled
with people who are not american
most of whom are not in compliance with
sort of basic american standards of free
speech and they'll do the work
okay so fine so january 6th happens and
donald trump tweets out a bunch of stuff
and puts out a bunch of facebook posts
none of them explicitly violate
facebook's rules it is very difficult to
see
how donald trump's posts many of which i
think are really bad
actually violate facebook's rules
there's way worse material on facebook
than
anything that trump put out on january
6th pretty clearly
but facebook and twitter and youtube
they all decided in coordination we're
going to take trump off the internet
right which is deeply dangerous that's
he was the sitting president of the
united states that's deeply dangerous
stuff
you now have the social media bros d
platforming
he's sitting presidents of the united
states because he said stuff that
doesn't explicitly even violate their
policies
so they did that on january 6th and
trump has just disappeared
and if you're a conservative you're
thinking okay if they can do that to the
president of the united states they can
certainly do that to me
like i haven't violated policies either
but trump really kind of didn't
i may not say things that are as
inflammatory as trump does but that's a
matter of arbitrary
kind of decision making there are people
at facebook who hate my guts they're
people youtube who hate my guts and
twitter will hate my guts they could
take me down at any time
and then the same time that that
happened parlor which was sort of the
alternative
was taken offline by amazon web services
so it became okay well you know what
conservatives you don't like how we run
our places here
well go build your own so somebody built
parlor as an alternative to twitter
and then after january 6th parlor is
completely taken off the internet by
amazon web services
okay so the social media companies just
have too much control over american life
which brings us
to the facebook oversight board so if
the facebook oversight board had done
the right thing here what they would
have said is
trump we don't like anything he said he
shouldn't have been banned
and certainly even if he had been banned
he should have been banned indefinitely
and he should be he should be back
already
instead facebook's oversight board found
today and they released
a decision and their decision is
facebook was right to ban trump at the
time
and while they cannot suspend trump
indefinitely they need to
you know re-meet on this thing in six
months so
all the way until the middle of june
late june
then they probably have to reconsider
about trump or maybe they don't
who the hell knows we'll get to this in
just
one second the the facebook decision
because it really is
a fairly absurd decision on nearly every
level
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so the reality is that if you've
got kids they're waking up at night
or maybe you just have to get up early
for work in the morning or you went to
bed late whatever it is
you need your sleep and the best way to
sleep is to sleep on a great mattress
that is made just for you which is what
helix sleep
does helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from it when we got our helix
sleep mattress it's really cool you just
kind of unwrap it and inflates in front
of you you pop it on the bed you're good
to go it's super simple just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you have to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that is helixsleep.com alrighty so
the oversight board has finally released
its long-awaited decision here's what
they say
the board has upheld facebook's decision
on january 7th 2021 to restrict
then president donald trump's access to
posting content on his facebook page and
instagram account however
it was not appropriate for facebook to
impose the indeterminate and
standardless penalty of indefinite
suspension
facebook's normal penalties include
removing the violating content imposing
a time-bound period of suspension
or permanently disabling the page and
account the board insists that facebook
review this matter to determine and
justify a proportionate response that is
consistent with the rules that are
applied to other users of its platform
facebook must complete its review of
this matter within six months of the
date of this decision
the board also made policy
recommendations for facebook to
implement in developing
clear necessary and proportionate
policies that promote public safety
and respect freedom of expression okay
well
all right so here's what they say about
the case and that's their decision their
decision is
you're right to ban trump also you can't
do it indefinitely also we have no
standard for when he has to be let back
so thank you for that
here's what they say about the case they
say elections are a crucial part of
democracy
on january 6th during the counting of
the 2020 electoral votes ahmad forcibly
entered the capitol building in
washington d.c
this violence threatened the
constitutional process five people died
and many more were injured during the
violence during these events then
president donald trump posted two pieces
of content
at 4 21 eastern standard time as the
riot continued trump posted a video on
facebook and instagram
i know you're paying i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen from
us it was a landslide election and
everyone knows it especially the other
side but you have to go home now
we have to have peace we have to have
law and order we have to respect our
great people in law and order we don't
want anybody hurt
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where such a
thing happened where they could take it
away from all of us from me from you
from our country this is a fraudulent
election but we can't play into the
hands of these people
we have to have peace so go home we love
you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the
other the way others are treated that
are so bad and so evil i know how you
feel but go home
and go in peace okay so i said at the
time
i'm not a big fan of that video because
that video says two conflicting things
one is
go home go in peace and also everything
you're super pissed about you ought to
be super duper pissed about and the
system has completely failed you but
also go home
right so it was conflicting did it
violate facebook's content standards
how really like how at 5 41 eastern
standard time facebook removed this post
for violating its community standard on
dangerous individuals and organizations
at 607 eastern standard time as police
were securing the capital trump posted a
written statement on facebook said these
are the things and events that happen
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously viciously stripped
away from great patriots who have been
badly unfairly treated for so long
go home with love in peace remember this
day forever again there's that
conflicting message same message
okay at 6 15 east 6 15 p.m eastern
standard time
facebook removed this post for violating
its community standard on dangerous
individuals and organizations and then
it blocked trump from posting on
facebook
and then facebook extended the block
indefinitely and for at least the next
two weeks until the peaceful transition
of power
is complete on january 20th trump sees
to be president
on january 21st facebook announced it
had referred this case
to the board so here are their findings
they say the board found that the two
posts by trump on january 6th
severely violated facebook's community
standards and instagram community
guidelines
we love you you're very special in the
first post and great patriots and
remember this day forever in the second
post
violated facebook's rules prohibiting
praise or support of people engaged in
violence okay here is where you start
going a little mad with the facebook
standards
how many members of the media said
that rioters and looters even though
they shouldn't riot even though they
shouldn't loot
are good people how many said these are
people who are just
justly aggrieved at the situation in the
united states yet cnn hosts who said
this
yet msnbc hosts who said this you had
politicians who said this you had kamala
harris
actively promoting bailout funds for
people who were arrested for rioting and
looting
so in what way do those people get to
stay but trump has to go
right the question isn't just whether
trump violated the standard the question
is
whether this standard even exists and
the answer is no it clearly does not
exist
it was implemented and snapped into
place with regard to trump it was left
completely irrelevant for months on end
while people rampaged through american
cities
resulting in dozens of deaths two
billion dollars in property damage the
most damaging riots in american history
politicians media members commentators
came out and defended the people who
were doing the rioting and looting
were any of those people banned from
facebook or even suspended
definitely the board found that in
maintaining an unfounded narrative of
electoral fraud and persistent calls to
action
mr trump created an environment where a
serious risk of violence was possible
okay so now
if you're gonna blame trump for creating
a serious risk of violence
through creating an environment how
about the entire media that has claimed
that police are systemically racist
america is systemically racist
and all of the injustices of the
criminal justice system
cannot be corrected because it is buried
deep in the roots of all of america's
institutions
again these are not standards a double
standard is not a standard it is a
non-standard it doesn't exist
at the time of mr trump's post there was
a clear immediate risk of harm and his
words of support for those involved in
the riots legitimized their violent
actions
as president mr trump had a high level
of influence the reach of his post was
large
with 35 million followers on facebook
and 24 million on instagram facebook was
justified in suspending trump's accounts
on january 6th
okay so the answer here is that anytime
they want to spend anybody for pretty
much any reason they can
they can jerry-rig a system in order to
make that happen that's what you should
take away from this that if you are
you if you are of the left and you
openly promote excuses for violence
if you if you're peter bynard and you're
constantly promoting excuses for
violence from actual terrorist groups in
the middle east are fine
if you are a if you are a person who
promoted riots and looting
throughout the summer or even if you
said that those people
shouldn't be doing that but you
understand why they're doing it they're
great people they're patriots
i mean there are people on cnn who
compare it to the boston tea party right
none of those people were removed only
trump was removed you don't have to love
what trump said to recognize
that the standard that facebook is
holding here is completely unsustainable
because it's not a standard at all and
that these folks have way too much power
in american life they literally took the
sitting presidents of the united states
off the internet
okay if you take somebody off of
facebook and instagram
and youtube and twitter you have
effectively destroyed their ability to
disseminate information at all
and that's the sitting president of the
united states okay so where here's where
the oversight board then goes then
they do what is i think the funniest
thing here they just tossed the ball
back
into the court of facebook right so the
facebook oversight board is supposed to
be independent and they're going to
relieve pressure on facebook and all
this
instead they just take the ball and
throw it right back to facebook so they
say
in applying this penalty facebook did
not follow a clear published procedure
indefinite suspensions are not described
in the company's content policies
facebook's normal penalties include
removing the violating content imposing
a time-bound period of suspension
or permanently disabling the page and
account it is facebook's role to create
necessary and proportionate penalties
that respond to severe violations of its
content policies
the board's role is to ensure that
facebook's rule and processes are
consistent with its content policies its
values and its human rights commitments
in applying a vague standardless penalty
and then referring this case to the
board to resolve
facebook seeks to avoid its
responsibilities the board declines
facebook requests
and insists facebook apply and justify a
defined penalty so they've said you have
three choices
you can remove the violating content and
leave the account you can impose a
time-bound period of suspension like six
months
or you can permanently disable the page
and you guys have to make the decision
so the great irony here is that facebook
was attempting
to throw the ball away from its help
and the board just threw it right back
at them so that's kind of hilarious so
facebook no matter what is caught in the
middle here
but there are a few things to be noted
here facebook's oversight board
is just recognizing a reality which is
that these standards don't exist
they don't exist and the media loves
that these standards don't exist this is
the best part
our establishment media they hate
facebook they hate twitter so long as
they are open platform so long as they
are closed platforms they love them
which is why you had brian
stelter saying that he was very upset
that the oversight board might let trump
back on the internet
he literally said this there are a lot
of members of this board that are free
speech advocates first amendment
absolutists in some cases that are going
to make an argument that
these platforms should not be in the
position of making these choices at all
if trump is brought back on facebook
it'll likely be
for those reasons but a lot of this has
to do with the memory hole
right the riot going down the memory
hole that's what fox and right media has
been trying to do
and i worry that this may be another
result of that
okay so um he's he's very worried that
that facebook might be too
pro free speech that would be such a
disaster for the media because if
they're pro-free speech
then um maybe cnn actually has
competitors
in the online space alrighty meanwhile
there is a vast debate breaking out in
the house gop
there is chaos inside the republican
party over
a simple question whether donald trump
won or lost the 2020 election apparently
this is of
grave consequence to the media it is a
grave consequence inside the
republican caucus because the idea that
is being promulgated by the media
is that unless you go out on tv every
single day
and say that joe biden won the election
fair and square in every possible way
then this means that you are a liar and
a bad person and you are promoting the
quote-unquote big lie and on the other
side trump is saying you're promoting
the big life you say that he lost the
election
and all of this okay well i want to talk
about that in a second
but i want to first mention that there
is a big lie that is promoted by the
democratic party like
continuously and you'll see why i'm
doing this this is not a what about ism
thing because
i'm not a fan of lies in either case
there's a lie that is promoted by the
democratic party and it is ensconced
in every area of media coverage it is
ensconced in every area of democratic
policy making
and that lie is that there is widespread
voter suppression happening throughout
republican states and that voter
suppression is directed to black
americans see one of the things the
democrats have banged on for a very very
long time
is the idea that they will always and
forever
have an increasing share of minority
votes and it turns out that the
demographics his destiny argument
is not a perfectly good argument
democrats basically bet
after 2008 when barack obama won the
sweeping victory with large majorities
of nearly every
subgroup in the united states including
white americans
it turns out that after 2008 barack
obama was not a popular president
his policies were not popular his
congress was swept out of power in 2010
and so barack obama did something
different he said i'm going to put
together this intersectional coalition
of historically dispossessed groups and
we are going to build a new coalition in
a coalition of the ascendant and this
ascendant coalition
is demographically different than the
old coalition and basically
this new coalition is growing the
republican coalition is going to be
whiter and it's going to die off
and this was not something that was
hiding the ball there there were
democrats like ronald brownstein overtly
saying this sort of stuff for years
talking about the browning of america
how this inevitably meant that the
republican party was on the outs and
democrats would win
forever more and there were some people
on the right who responded to this
in similarly unconscionable fashion
suggesting the demographics was destiny
and that if we had
too many people of particular races that
this meant that republicans could never
win again and conservative principles
were dead
it's not true okay so the reality is
that this isn't true
the reality is that human beings are
individuals and though what we are
seeing in the united states is in fact
shifting in voting patterns and in 2020
donald trump won an outsized chair
compared to other republicans of the
latino vote for example
donald trump actually did better with
black voters in 2020 than he did in
2016.
even the new york times is now
acknowledging that rising diversity
might not help democrats as much as they
hope
according to nate cohn the census bureau
released two important sets of data last
week that have
big implications for american politics
and that challenged some prevailing
assumptions for both democrats and
republicans
the first set of data lays out long-term
demographic trends widely thought to
favor democrats
hispanics asian americans and
multiracial voters grew as a share of
the electorate
over the last few presidential races and
white voters who historically tend to
back the gop
fell to 71 in 2020 from 73
in 2016. the other data set tells a
second story
population growth continues to
accelerate in the south and the west
so much so that some republican-leaning
states in those regions are gaining more
electoral college votes
the states won by president biden will
be worth 303 electoral votes down from
306 electoral votes in 2020.
the demographic the democratic
disadvantage in the electoral college
just got worse again says the new york
times
these demographic and population shifts
are powerfully clarifying about
electoral politics in america
the increasing racial diversity among
voters isn't doing quite as much to help
democrats as liberals hope or to hurt
republicans as much
as conservatives fear because here's the
thing
republicans win a very very large share
of the hispanic vote in both texas and
florida for example
why well because they do better outreach
than they do in places like california
and also because not all latino and
hispanic voters are from the same
country
there's a difference between cuban
voters for example and mexican voters in
terms of voting patterns
which makes sense those are different
countries okay there is a difference in
how people vote
some of it is cultural and much of it is
individual one of the things that people
who study demographics have been
noticing is that an increasing share of
hispanic and latino voters identify as
white now
why well because they don't wish to see
themselves particularly
as displaced people from a home country
but rather as really non-ethnically
based
right this is it's a weird kind of thing
that's been happening it's why you see
on census bureau data
people will ask you are you are you
hispanic are you hispanic who identifies
as white right these are actual
demographic categories that appear on
census bureau
forums now okay well what this suggests
the democratic
demographics are not destiny and so the
entire democratic
agenda item which was we will get more
people in the intersectional coalition
vote for us and will ignore the rest of
america
is not likely to win them everlasting
victory and so what they have to do is
scare the living hell out of people of
minority persuasion
people people who are ethnic ethnic
minorities in the united states the
democrats are going to scare the living
hell out of them
in order to scare the living hell out of
them they have to lie right this is why
you see the democrats continually
suggesting
that voter laws they call for voter id
are in fact a form of voter suppression
and the idea from people like stacey
abrams is that limiting voting rights is
on the republican agenda
that they want to stop black people from
voting that they want to stop hispanic
people from voting
that they desperately want to stop
minority people from voting the
republican party
and this is why you see joe biden out
there suggesting over and over that
voting laws
that are looser in georgia than they are
in places like new york in many ways
are actually jim crow that's not true
it's a scare tactic
so this is the big lie being told by the
democratic party is that there is a
threat
to black america not only from white
america but particularly from
conservative america and stacey abrams
pushes this every day
and the media eat it up the media
featured her on the covers of magazines
the democratic party featured her during
the dnc
in a gubernatorial roundtable as though
she had won the governorship of georgia
even though she lost by 50 000 votes
it's hilarious the same democratic party
that says trump lost georgia by 13
000 votes undeniably lost georgia i mean
look at it
they say that governor stacey abrams is
governor even though she lost my 50 000
votes in the same state
but stacey abrams promotes this day in
and day out here she was for example
yesterday
talking about how republicans want
autocracy
the forerunners of autocracy and
authoritarianism
begin with limiting who has access to
the right to vote
making it so difficult that people give
up and abandon the perquisites of
democracy
that makes it much easier for those who
do not intend to share
power to hoard it and so i am deeply
afraid and
it seems like slightly hyperbolic but in
a nation like the us with its changing
demography
if the response to increased
participation by communities of color
by young people by women if the response
is to restrict their
access and impede their participation
that is a
very very strong signal that we are
heading in the wrong direction
right notice the open argument there
from stacey abrams as the demographics
of the country change democrats are
going to win more seats the only way
that won't happen is if republicans
stymie the voting processes and this is
why we need things like hr1
we need a giant overhaul of america's
electoral law so that people like stacey
abrams can promote ballot harvesting and
promote no voter id and all of the rest
of this
and now here's the problem it's just not
true voter suppression is not a major
problem in the united states
in fact voter suppression is so much of
a not major problem in the united states
that black voters
in many of these swing states going all
the way back to 2008 outvote their
share of the population this is the big
lie right the big lie pushed by the
democrats
and when i say the big lie i don't mean
like the biggest of lies which is
holocaust denial i mean it is a big lie
pushed by democrats today
that voter suppression is a major
problem in the united states it is just
not true in the wall street journal
today
there is a piece titled what was that
about voter suppression from the
editorial board
census figures released thursday show
that turnout in 2020 reached a near
historic high for a presidential
election with 66.8 percent of voting age
citizens casting ballots
0.9 percentage points shy of the 1992
record
turnout was 5.4 percentage points higher
than in 2016
3.2 points higher than in 2008 when
barack obama drove scores of young
people and minorities to the polls
the share of hispanics 53.7 percent and
asians 59
a voting age who cast ballots also hit
new peaks black voting 62.6 percent
surpassed any presidential year
save 2008 and 2012 when barack obama was
on the ballot
notably gop states with stricter voting
rules didn't experience
significantly lower minority turnout
black turnout was highest in maryland
75.3 percent followed by mississippi
72.8 percent
and lowest in massachusetts 36.4
liberals have lambasted georgia for
purging voters and restricting ballot
access but georgia had a smaller black
white voting gap in illinois new jersey
virginia and california
all states controlled by democrats the
states the biggest black black white
voting gaps
massachusetts oregon wisconsin iowa and
colorado
three allow same-day voter registration
good luck trying to discern a link
between the state's voting rules
partisan control
and minority turnout so in other words
it's just not true
okay the idea that there is a vast
attempt
to stop the demographic wave of the
united states the new demographic wave
through voter suppression it's not true
but it is a key talking point for
democrats because it fosters their
entire agenda it suggests that
republicans are racist
trying to stop black people from voting
it suggests you need federalized control
top down of voting protocols taking
power away from the states
and it underlines the idea that as the
demographics of the united states change
the destiny of the united states changes
right so this is the lie that is being
pushed by democrats and every democratic
leader mirrors it
and so do members of the media there's
an entire article in the
new in the washington post today about
how two black ceos got corporate america
to pay attention
to voting rights and of course it is
this it is the sycophantic
slobbering piece about how kenneth
chinolt
has pushed people to incorporate america
to mirror his political priorities
chinook went on to run american express
for 17 years one of just 19
black chief executives ever at a fortune
500 company
chanel recently used his formula
fighting for change when he and another
black chief executive kenneth frazier
of the pharmaceutical giant merck helped
push much of corporate america to
publicly oppose the restrictive voting
rights bills being considered in dozens
of states
so again the idea here from the media
from the democrats from from everybody
in power
is a lie it is a lie that black voters
are being suppressed at the polls it is
not true
and stacey abrams the great heroine of
the democratic side of the aisle
she has been promoting that lie ad
nauseum okay all of which goes to show
you
why the democratic party among polls of
republicans i mean among polls of
democrats democratic base
loves the democratic party there's a big
difference between that and the
republican base which basically hates
the republican party
if you take polls of democrats and their
approval ratings for the democratic
party
very very high for as long as i can
recall republican base
been a giant gap with the republican
party and one of the reasons for that
is because they believe i think quite
correctly that republicans publicly do
not mirror their priorities
it's one of the reasons that they had a
very strong attachment to trump because
trump
whatever else you can say about the guy
and there's a lot to say about him he
did have his finger on the pulse of what
the base wanted to talk about
now maybe he said things in some ways
maybe he shouldn't have talked about
those things
possible but he certainly had his finger
on the pulse of what the base wanted to
talk about
more than your typical republican
leadership did
this is breaking out into the open right
now with regard to the future of the
republican party and it's really
breaking out into the open in
controversy surrounding
representative liz cheney of wyoming
we'll get to the issue in just
one second first if you're a business
owner who is hiring you'll probably face
a lot of challenges when it comes to
finding the right person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in the haystack sure
you can post your job to some job board
but then all you can do is hope the
right person comes along which is why
you should try instead
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com dailywire
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 top job sites
with just one click
then zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zipper career is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
non-zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the very first day it's
no wonder
over 2.3 million businesses have come to
zip recruiter for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options
zip recruiter finds you what you are
looking for the needle in the haystack
right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this web address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again remember head on
over to this unique magical place at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire we've been using zippercrew
for years here at dailywire because
whenever we want to upgrade
our employees we always check out
ziprecruiter zippercareer is indeed the
smartest way to hire ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e as you all know the
daily wire has been growing
like crazy i mean just in the few months
of the year we released our first movie
we struck up a movie deal with junior
carano we launched a new talk show
hosted by candace owens we launched a
new show hosted by me
all in the last six months and we moved
our entire company by the way to
nashville
and my branch of the company to florida
we've been moving at the speed of light
so thank you
for your support thank you guys you're
the ones who make all of this possible
and
we want to continue to include you in
all of our future plans every day on the
show i talk about a lot of amazing
products and services from sponsors that
i personally love and use but we want to
get to know you better so we can
actually tailor our sponsors to you
please go to dailywire.com shapiro fill
out my audience survey
tell us a little bit more about yourself
and to sweeten that whole experience
those of you that do complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000
gift card which is a great deal you can
only take that survey once per daily
wire show
if you want to increase your chances of
winning a thousand bucks go listen to
michael mulls
that's the only reason to listen to
nulls andrew clavin or matt walsh to get
access to their surveys as well
again my survey link is dailywire.com
shapiro we would love
to hear from you also if you didn't
catch last night's episode of candace
don't worry
you can still watch the full interview
with her and president donald trump he
stops by if you're a daily wire member
they discuss everything
from the media's attacks against him and
melania to whether he is considering
another presidential run
in 2024 if you haven't joined daily wire
yet hurry now this is your last chance
to get 25
off a new membership with code candace
before the discount ends this thursday
may 6th
make sure you grab the audio podcast on
apple spotify or wherever your platform
of choice may be
candace says things the mainstream media
simply will not
just head on over to apple podcast or
spotify subscribe to candace today be
sure to leave a five star review if you
like what you hear you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so while the democratic party tends
to
reflect the priorities of its own voters
the republican party very often does not
so liz cheney has gotten into hot water
with other members of the republican
party
particularly including president trump
because she keeps saying over and over
that trump lost the 2020 election
now i've been saying literally since the
day of the election
that i was waiting to see evidence of
massive voter fraud and massive voter
irregularity that would explain trump's
loss in the swing states i didn't see
that
presented by trump i really didn't see
that presented by anybody doesn't mean
there wasn't voter fraud doesn't mean
there wasn't voter irregularity
in an election that included hundreds of
millions of americans presumably there
would be
but that does not mean that the margins
were small enough
that you would see a shift of 13 000
votes in georgia or 12 000 votes in
arizona or 80 000 votes in pennsylvania
or 120 000 votes in michigan or 14 000
votes in wisconsin
those are big margins those are not tiny
margins when it comes to absolute number
of votes
that you would have to show were either
falsified or were thrown out
and in fact the trump campaign didn't
even make those allegations in its court
filings its court filings were mainly
about the unfairness of the rules
in some cases like pennsylvania there
was credence to that but that still does
not change the fact that you have to
demonstrate actual evidence that voter
fraud or regularity
decide an election if you're going to
claim that voter fraud or regularity
decided the election
i've said at the same time that i think
the real rigging of the election was not
done
on the level of voting i think the real
rigging of the election was done by the
media throughout the election cycle and
before
i think the media routinely lied about
trump i think they routinely lied about
biden i think that they hid
biden's radicalism i think they allowed
biden to hide in the basement and not
answer a single difficult question
i think that they overtly stymied the
new york post story about hunter biden
in the month before the election i think
they lied about trump being a russian
asset for four years
i think a lot of things impacted the
2020 elections
and that included of course donald trump
making some rather large boo-boos during
the election campaign
but the reality is that if the media had
covered that thing anything
like they should have covered that thing
it would have been a much closer
election at the very least and because
it was a pretty close election in the
swing states
i have very little doubt that if they
for example fairly covered what was
going on
with covet as opposed to presenting
andrew cuomo with the man of the year
award every single day while he
proceeded to kill all the olds in new
york
and if they had covered the black lives
matter riots that were happening
throughout the country
in june as they should have then
i think trump probably would have won
despite the pandemic
okay so do i think that that trump it
depends on your definition of fairly i
suppose
if you think that trump lost the
election because of voter fraud and
regularity i disagree if you think that
trump lost the election
because the election because all the
institutions of power were basically
rigged against trump i think there's
certainly some truth to that okay
so you can say all of that and the
republican base may disagree on some of
the fraud and irregularity arguments but
the republican base is willing to hear
that what they don't want and this is
really what it comes down to for liz
cheney
is liz cheney keeps going out on places
like msnbc
and then she keeps telling those anchors
exactly what they want to hear
this is the problem you can say
everything that i've just said
and the republican base will not be
angry with you the republican base
understands
that there are a lot of decent arguments
for the
the notion that trump lost the election
in terms of the number of votes
but that there are a lot of mitigating
factors that led to him losing
that really were rigged against him the
republican base can hear that
but the republican base does not want to
hear is that if you are somebody
who believes that trump got jobs in some
way during the election this means that
you are a promulgator of the big lie
and this means that you are a traitor to
the united states and you're undermining
american politics and polity
in other words if you're in a leadership
position in the republican party
what you say matters because you are
considered a representative of the base
i agree with liz cheney that voter fraud
and regularity
did not decide the 2020 election i just
think that liz cheney's
public facing priorities are not at all
the public facing priorities of the
republican party
the republican party right now should
not be focused on answering questions
from the media
about whatever donald trump's latest
missive is about the 2020 election
the 2020 election happened in in
november the electoral college voted in
december
last i checked the calendar now says
it's may okay it is not time to talk
about that
and if the media insist on talking about
that as a republican you have every
right and indeed every obligation to say
i don't know why we're talking about
that why aren't we talking about the
fact that the current president of the
united states
joe biden is doing a terrible job why
aren't we talking about the looming
inflationary crisis that's going to hit
the country why
aren't we talking about the border
crisis that you and politico refuse to
even say is a crisis
why aren't we talking about the fact
that joe biden's economic plans spend
more money than has ever been created in
human history
why are you still talking about trump
and the answer is the media wants to
talk about trump because the media want
to misdirect the media don't want to
cover what's going on in the white house
the media would prefer not to talk
about the fact that democrats are lying
about things like voter suppression
in fact they wish to promulgate those
myths so you'll see the media on their
high horse about
voter fraud and regularity and we we
can't feature people on our networks who
say this kind of stuff
fine then don't feature anybody on your
network who says that voter suppression
is a major issue
in republican states because guess what
it ain't you don't have any data to show
that voter suppression is a major issue
in the republican states so if you're
gonna have a standard
have it be the same standard but i don't
think that there's the same standard i
think there's a double standard
and this is what liz cheney fails to
appreciate apparently
okay so kevin mccarthy who is the house
minority leader and he wishes to be the
house majority
speaker he wishes to be the speaker of
the house and by the way if republicans
somehow find a way
to lose maintain a maintain a minority
in the house in 2022
every single person in a leadership
position in the republican party should
be fired there is no
way republicans should lose the house in
2022 no
freaking way the policies of the
democrats are unpopular
they're going to start to bear ugly
fruit they already are in terms of
violence in america's major cities
there's a reason that there's a net
population gain in the south and in the
west and in
red states particularly well blue states
are losing population there is a reason
for that
if republicans cannot make hay while the
sun shines in 2022
they deserve to lose their leadership
positions right so liz cheney has sort
of been
under fire for a while and you'll
remember a few months ago liz cheney was
merely asked about january 6th
and she said that january 6 was terrible
which is true and then there were some
people in the republican party who
basically tried a vote of no confidence
against her and it failed
and she got up in conference and she
said that she believes what she believes
and then the majority of the conference
basically said okay fine you can stay
well then liz cheney felt like she had
to get into a bleep fight with trump
right trump said something about how liz
cheney's the worst and instead of liz
cheney just ignoring him
which is what she should have done
politically instead she decided to jump
right in
and be like donald trump's a
prevaricator donald trump is is the
promoter of the big lot
even if she believes that which she's
perfectly entitled to do
i have a question what does that have to
do with your job
as the number three in the house
seriously like speaking the truth is
always your job i get it
but there is also a truth that is
you as a powerful person in the
republican party have an obligation to
forward the republican agenda that's why
you were hired so are you forwarding the
conservative and republican agenda
not by saying that sort of stuff but by
making that your chief focus in the
media by earning
strange new respect from chris hayes at
msnbc
is that forwarding the agenda okay so
kevin mccarthy got caught on a hot mic
talking to i believe it was steve ducey
of fox and friends
about liz cheney and he said listen i
i'm not sure i can hold back the tide
here against liz cheney and frankly it
seems like her focus
is more on getting attention for saying
this sort of stuff even if it's true
then it is unforwarding the agenda again
two things can be true at once one she
can be saying some true things
and two it ain't forwarding the agenda
the republican party it is serving i
don't even know what her agenda would be
like on
a practical level but it is certainly
forwarding the agenda of a media that
wish to keep focused on donald
trump at all times under all
circumstances
i think she's got real problems i i i've
had it with
i've had it with it's you know i've lost
confidence
well someone just has to bring a motion
but i assume that will probably take
place
okay so there are a bunch of polls that
came out and they suggested that liz
cheney is in trouble in wyoming and
trump had tweeted at her and it turned
into this bleep fight
and again here is the issue for liz
cheney your job is to fight
the the forwarding of the democratic
agenda which by the way is the most
radical progressive agenda
that we have seen in our lifetimes it
makes barack obama look like a
and if your chief focus day in and day
out is how do i answer questions from
msnbc
you are not doing your job properly it's
also a good indicator the democrats are
jumping on this of course so nancy
pelosi of course is out there defending
liz cheney
there should be again when when nancy
pelosi's defending you it's a pretty
good indicator
that even if you're right you've sort of
walked down the wrong
path politically here okay nancy there's
a difference between
pragmatism and uh and
you know what what is happening right
now i will say nancy pelosi is a liar
nancy pelosi says things that are untrue
repeatedly nancy pelosi promoted the
idea that donald trump was a russian
collusion advocate that donald trump was
a russian tool
she promoted the idea that voter
suppression would decide the 2020
election
i mean she's just a liar but here's
nancy pelosi praising liz cheney's a
truth teller which is always
not a great sign i do commend
lintani for her courage for her
patriotism
and i wish her well uh
perhaps this challenge will make her
stronger i don't know
that's up to their caucus i don't uh
welcome their participation in our
caucus and i'm sure they don't welcome
my participation
and there okay so the the liz cheney's
response to all of this
has been to double down and and to
basically give the media the issue they
want which is the republican infighting
over january 6 the republican infighting
over trump
again you have a response there are two
responsibilities one is to tell the
truth
and the other is to forward the
republican agenda and what people hired
you to do was both
okay so i've so liz cheney put out a
statement her spokesman did
this is about whether the republican
party is going to perpetuate lies about
the 2020 election an attempt to
whitewash what happened on january 6th
liz will not do that that is the issue
no that is not the issue
i won't whitewash that either i've been
very very clear about what i thought
happened in the 2020 election i just
said it five seconds ago
i've been very clear what i think about
january 6th which was a bunch of droogs
and morons participating
in an act of anti-democratic
authoritarianism
i thought january 6 was quite terrible
you'll recall i still think it was quite
terrible
i think it was some of the worst imagery
just in terms of pure imagery
in the united states since september
11th hey i think is really really bad
also i think the democratic agenda to
take over every institution in america
and then weaponize it against american
freedoms
is significantly greater threat than a
bunch of morons and drugs running into
the capitol building and promptly
getting their asses arrested
and by the way failing in their mission
to stop the electoral certification
taking place
and as far as donald trump and his
beliefs about the voter regularity and
voter fraud of the election it was
republican secretaries of state
and it was republican mitch mcconnell
and it was vice president mike pence who
certified that election
end of story okay you can say all of
those things and still not fall into the
trap of
i'm going to run over to the democratic
media to talk about how terrible the
rest of my republican colleagues are
for saying different things and this is
why liz cheney is on the outs today
okay republicans have a tendency to want
to answer every question from the media
and they don't
have to do it they don't have to do it
it's a mistake
you see this from the governor of of
west virginia went on
i think it was cnn to talk about his
push for for a ban on transgender
athletes playing
in opposite sports leagues so men
playing in women's leagues if they
believe that they're women for example
he went on cnn he got brown beaten by a
report why why
just don't do it there's no there's no
law that says you have to do that
there's no law that says that you have
to answer every question from msnbc
and by the way if you do answer a
question from msnbc you can give your
honest opinion and then you can
also swivel and clock msnbc for its bias
and for the lies that it tells
that's not moral equivalence that would
be honesty
it is honesty to say that you don't
think the 2020 election was stolen via
voter fraud and regularity
you do think that the media did an awful
job you think they perverted the minds
of americans and told them a pack of
lies and continue to tell them packs of
lies that pervert the cause
of american freedom you can say all
those things at once
but where you put your focus does matter
when you're in a position of political
leadership
so that is where things stand with uh
with liz cheney today my understanding
is that uh liz cheney is in trouble
inside the house republican caucus
and then if she gets ousted presumably
we will have a bevy of wonderful stories
from the media about how the republicans
have doubled down
on the fraud and lies of january 6th and
november
or alternatively they just don't think
liz cheney is being an effective leader
on behalf of the party how about that
because that seems like the question at
issue here
i believe two things at once liz cheney
is not incorrect in her assessment
of voter fraud and regularity in 2020 or
in her assessment of january 6th
and also she's not being an effective
leader for the republican party right
now
both of those things can be true
absolutely at once
alrighty so meanwhile the democratic
agenda continues to roll out
janet yellen the secretary of the
treasury really spooked investors
yesterday
and she spooked investors because she is
not great at her job
i understand that everybody thinks janet
yellen's graded her job because she just
keeps inflating the currency
but the reality is that the federal
reserve acted for years
as the chief economic policy maker in
the united states as opposed to congress
and now you have congress blowing out
the spending in extraordinary ways
and janet yellen the treasury secretary
being like yeah what if we just kept
printing money what if we just kept
doing that so yesterday she made a
boo-boo
and she actually spooked the markets the
markets dropped because she was like
there might be inflation but don't worry
the fed can handle it
which is like um i thought you said a
minute ago there wasn't going to be any
serious inflation so here's janet yellen
spooking the markets
it may be that interest rates will have
to rise somewhat to
make sure that our economy doesn't
overheat
even though the additional spending is
relatively
small relative to the size of the
economy
so it could cause some very modest
increases in interest rates
to get that reallocation okay and
everybody went um
what now because you were saying five
seconds ago that you weren't worried at
all
about inflation well then she walked
that back according to the washington
post treasury secretary ellen insisted
tuesday she's not concerned about the
risks of economic overheating
hours after earlier comments about
inflation caused a brief panic on wall
street and invited
fresh scrutiny about the white house's
position in an interview with the
atlantic released tuesday morning
yellen defended the administration's new
spending proposals and said that the
central bank could handle inflationary
pressures with modest interest
rate increases raising interest rates
can slow the pace of economic growth by
increasing the cost of borrowing
okay well then she walked it back at a
separate event with the wall street
journal later on tuesday
yellen was adamant she was not concerned
about inflation and stressed she was not
predicting or recommending an imminent
increase in rates
so i don't think there's going to be an
inflationary problem but if there is the
fed can be counted on to address them
well here's the problem of course all of
these folks keep suggesting that they
can keep
blowing up the currency and nothing will
happen economists at the bank of america
global research
said u.s policymakers are testing the
limits of goldilocks
they are trying to heat up the economy
as fast as possible without generating
serious inflation
but what we have seen is that there is
serious inflation particularly for
commodities
there's been a big backlog of orders on
on basic commodities
we talked about this yesterday on the
program the prices are going up there's
not enough labor in the economy people
are not re-entering the labor force
because we are paying people to stay
home
jen sack he said we take inflationary
risks incredibly seriously except for
how you don't
okay because if you did you wouldn't be
talking about spending two trillion
dollars every three weeks
biden has proposed more than four
trillion dollars of additional spending
that would be infused into the economy
over the course of the decade
the white house says those programs are
accounted for with tax increases but
that's not true
so even janet yellen is starting to to
hint around the idea that perhaps
there's going to be inflation and
everybody who's watching kind of knows
this meanwhile the crisis at the borah
continues
to to marinate it's not getting any
better
and jen sackey is out there saying this
is all trump's fault remember
how refreshing she always told the truth
according to brian stelter at cnn
after four years of an immigration
system rooted in destructive and chaotic
policies
president biden is taking the challenge
head on and is building a fair
orderly and humane immigration system
that's our objective
after coming into office our
administration immediately jumped into
action
to address the influx of migrants at the
border something that began
during and was exacerbated by the trump
administration
nope you haven't done any of that stuff
you haven't you haven't mitigated it you
made it better
you just got the media to stop talking
about it for five seconds that's all
that's happened here
they put kamala harris on the problem
the vice president of the united states
who giggles inappropriately and weirdly
she actually shocker the democratic
party
honestly their politics is basically
just a pagan cult at this point
whatever is the issue that they wish to
address becomes the cause of all things
it's like a pagan cult praying to the
sun because
they they want the weather to change
except they pray to the sun because they
want climate change
to be the cause of of migration
or something it's so weird like they
keep saying this kind of stuff
and they'll say things like oh an uptick
in violence in america's major cities
that's systemic racism or
alternatively it's because you keep
screwing with the police like there's a
major influx of migrants on the southern
border who are
openly saying to the media we're coming
because biden's president and you get
kamala harris being like oh it's
probably climate change
or it could be you know the thing that
is obviously causing the major influx to
the southern border
here was kamala here is blaming climate
change for
migration to the southern border even
though climate change is a slow and
ongoing process over the course of the
century and yet we have seen a historic
spike in the number of miners arriving
on america's southern border without
without people or adults accompanying
them
we are focused on addressing both the
acute factors
and the root causes of migration i
believe this is an important distinction
we must focus on both first
the acute factors the catastrophes
that are causing people to leave right
now
the hurricanes the pandemic the drought
and extreme food insecurity
and then there are the long-standing
issues
the root causes and i'm thinking of
corruption
violence and poverty the lack of
economic opportunity
the lack of climate adaptation and
climate resilience
so we need to stop migration on the
southern border
through a carbon tax that will have an
incremental
decrease and effect on the temperature
over the course of 100 years
or alternatively you could enforce
border law
this lady by the way still has not been
down on the border the vice president
still has not been down on the board
they put her in charge of the border
what two and a half months ago and there
she is speaking at some sort of
conference about climate change and the
border crisis
amazing in her job amazing again if
republicans cannot win back the house
because they're so divided over whatever
thing trump put out on donald j
trump.com trump by the way said that he
was putting out a social media service
yesterday he didn't he put up like a
blog on his website
that allows you to tweet out his
thoughts to everybody else that's fine
but it's not a social media service
if your chief concern right now is trump
and going into 2022
liz cheney allows trump to be the number
one issue
then republicans are somehow going to
blow it which is incredible because
democrats have blown it democrats are
continuing
to blow it on covet democrats are
blowing it
i mean for example gen saki at the white
house yesterday defended the cdc
okay so it turns out the cdc used the
american federation of teachers guidance
to create school guidelines now the
american federation of teachers last i
checked are not scientists the cdc is
the center for disease control
it is literally their job to just
present the data to you
and instead they had randy weingarten
rewrite all of the school standards
and then they trotted that out as though
it was scientific
the entire media declared throughout the
trump administration that trump was
perverting the science this
administration openly does it and then
defends it and nobody seems to give a
damn here's jen sackey at the white
house
saying it's totally fine to have the
american federation of teachers and the
one of the worst people in american
politics randy weingarten
write the standards for school
reopenings it's actually long-standing
best practice
for the cdc to engage with organizations
and groups that are going to be impacted
by guidance and recommendations issued
by the agency it doesn't mean they are
taking everything they want or even a
percentage of what they want but it's
important to understand the
implementation components they do so to
ensure
that recommendations are feasible and
that they adequately
address the safety and well-being of the
individuals the guidance is aimed to
protect
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous i mean
these are tools of the teachers unions
and then they trot that out americans
are not going to abide by this
they still by the way are trying out
anthony fauci who's just a joke at this
point
he's a bad joke nobody ought to pay
attention to anthony fouch because he
doesn't know what the hell he's talking
about he says things that make no sense
according to other experts according to
people who know better than anthony
fauci
i don't know how anthony fought should
become america's doctor first of all all
the best doctors i know are working in
the private sphere they're not working
for the nia id
and all the epidemiologists that i know
and i've gotten to know several
over the course of the last year working
at places like johns hopkins and
stanford
look at the fact that this guy's been
working for the government they look at
government employees the same way you
look at government employees
they're like um no that's not no anyway
anthony fauci who is treated as some
sort of religious figure he keeps saying
stupid crap that makes no sense he was
on cnn yesterday
again remember he's heading up biden's
covid team
he said yesterday we're at the bottom of
the sixth inning what is this a seven
inning game
is it gonna get called on account of
rain how in the world are we at the
bottom of the sixth inning are you
insane
are you an insane person we have the
lowest rate
of covet death that we have had in
probably a year in the united states
and it's declining and your answer is
we're in the bottom of the sixth inning
if you're a crazy person here's anthony
fauci
what inning are we in as far as this
coveted pandemic is concerned
well you know i i we're at least halfway
through i
i hope we're seeing and and i do believe
uh uh
wolf i'm not trying to be overly uh
enthusiastic about what's going on
vis-a-vis
the vaccine program which is so
successful but we've really got to not
declare victory
prematurely how about the the bottom of
the six
try that one i'll go with the bottom of
the six that's not too bad
other things that anthony fauci has said
over the last 24 hours
anthony fauci also said that the cdc
guidelines on summer camps quote
i wouldn't call them excessive i would
say they're conservative
okay here are the um here are the
guidelines for summer camps okay now we
know a few things one
kids do not die from covid okay the
number of kids who have died from
that is as a of course there are people
who die from every cause but
the number of kids who died from covet
is significantly lower than the number
of kids you die from the flu every year
fewer than 300 kids have died in the
united states of covet out of hundreds
of thousands who have been infected with
kelvin
second everybody who's older in the
united states
has already had the opportunity to get a
vaccine in fact everybody over the age
of 16 in the united states has had the
opportunity to get a vaccine
so you shouldn't be telling little kids
that they have to mask up in 90 degree
weather outdoors and stay away from each
other it's idiotic
it's foolish okay here is the cdc
guidance all staff and kids masked at
all times even outdoors
cohorts for kids three foot distance
within cohorts six feet without
limit shared objects like toys and
sports equipment except that the cdc
explicitly now says
that you don't have to wipe down your
counters surfaces are not
vectors of transmission no close contact
sports or indoor sports
outdoor sports should be masked these
are the standards from the cdc
and anthony fauci that dope he's like i
wouldn't say that's except
you wouldn't say that's excessive
americans are looking at you guys and
saying what the hell are you doing
meanwhile we got this adult old
president who's going around doing
completely nonsensical things
right he goes over to jimmy carter's
house and jimmy carter is like a
thousand years old
and and unfortunately in not completely
good health
he goes over to anthony he goes over to
jimmy carter's house takes the weirdest
picture of all time looks like
george murrison standing next to mugsy
bogues and
then he proceeds to unmask with the old
dude
and you're like uh didn't you just say
you're supposed to mask and then he
walks out of the house and he puts back
on the mask
because joe biden is not coherent on any
of this crap it's all virtue signaling
nonsense from joe biden here is joe
biden telling you that you know what
you know what you you need to
keep following the cct clb
gtq guidelines now that we have the
vaccine supply
we're focused on convincing even more
americans to show up
and get the vaccine that is available to
them
if we succeed in this effort as we did
with the last
then americans will have taken a serious
step towards return to normal that's
july 4th but we're not there yet
that's why i'm asking people to continue
to follow the ccd guidance cdc
guidelines as we work to get more more
people vaccinated yeah listen to this
incoherence called dope i mean i'm sorry
as we work to get
more people vaccinated you know what
we're watching right now yesterday so we
were up to like three and a half million
people being vaccinated every day we are
now down to
lower than a million vaccine doses
issued yesterday you know why because we
have demand fall off
you know why we have demand falloff
because idiots like this and anthony
fauci keep saying that even after you're
vaccinated you have to keep masking
and mask your kids and send them outside
in 95 degree weather
and keep them six feet apart that's why
the demand is falling off it's why
people don't want to get the vaccine
there are polls that demonstrate this i
cited them yesterday on the show
among geo peers for example there's an
gap between people who say they will get
the vaccine if they can't take off if
they if they have to keep the mask on
and then people who say they'll get the
vaccine if they can take the mask off
an 18 percentage point jump in
enthusiasm for the vaccine
that's just among people in the gop and
yet biden keeps promoting this stupidity
that masks are the greatest protector
rather than the vaccine
here was biden doing that yesterday oh
masks they they're needlessly
dividing the kambaju the country entry
basketball
cd we can continue to drive vaccinations
up
and case loads down we'll need our mask
even less
and less i know it will take time to get
everyone back to everything back to
normal you know we're all going to have
to be patient with one another
mass have needlessly divided this
country
masking as directed as a patriotic duty
but so too is treating each other with
respect and patience
treat each other with respect and
patience unless somebody unmasks
publicly
in the middle of a street with nobody
around then that person is being
unpatriotic he literally said
you should mask up for patriotism and
now he's like yeah we need to be
tolerant to other people
he's he's just the worst he's just by
the way there will be a backlash
if republicans don't blow it so don't
blow it you idiots
how about represents the anti-biden
agenda because his agenda sucks
it's garbage is going to cause inflation
it's going to keep people out of the
workforce
it's going to continue to cause racial
conflagrations across the country
it's going to cause continued confusion
about covet and what you can and cannot
do
the backlash is right there this is low
hanging fruit for republicans and
instead you dopes aside that you want to
argue
over the 2020 election enough
enough if you're not dedicated to the
agenda of stopping this sort of
authoritarian crap
then get the hell out of the way there's
plenty of space in the commentary
i'm sure cnn has a chair open for you if
that's what you want to do
but you're not there to earn strange new
respect you're there to stop
this agenda and reverse it if possible
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour in the meantime
go check out the michael moles show on
today's episode michael will be talking
about some breaking news
bill and melinda gates are getting a
divorce
so i guess there is just another that's
another microsoft bug that episode is
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam scievents audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
bill and melinda gates get divorced
fauchi
prolongs the lockdowns and a new
celebrity prepares
a run for president check it out on the
michael knoll show